hi there we're gearing up for the
world's most important bike race this
will be the hundreds and first tour and
this year it's beginning right here in
the United Kingdom why well that's a
question we can put to the director of
the Tour de France who joins us right
now Christian thanks for being here so
what are you jumping and jumping on the
back of the success that cycling had
here with the Olympics or jumping back
to the start of the tool through
qualifying London interested and seven
it was really unforgettable and it was
such a success such a question so many
people huge crowds and at that time we
thought we would be back ten years after
12 years after but the results of the
Olympic Games and the first win of a
British rider in the tour and cilantro
is bradley wiggins made us decided that
we had to come back as soon as possible
and we are here in 2014 what's really
going to stand out in this tool I think
it will be a brush one of the most
popular only part ever because there is
such a passion here and after I hope a
big battle between Chris Froome the
defending champion alberto contador
vincenzo nibali and perhaps as a new
colombian guy who won who won balinese I
don't know and perhaps some French guys
because it will be 20 in 29 years after
the last Victoria french-fried 92 and
your money is on I don't know I don't
know but as an organizer what I wish is
a battle to the end in the last mountain
stage and to the last time trial that
would be best for business so tell me
how is the business of the Tour de
France I mean particularly after the
departure of Lance Armstrong where do
things stand yeah those are two it's
very different from all the other race
we can suffer in the other races we
organize as it was very different we
have 250 bits four stages of the tool
and we are only 30 to 35 places every
year so so and the true is really
different it's not only
sports is there more money in
professional cycling now or less since
Armstrong left I have no also in
provision cycling the teams are tuna
more money now it's it's it's more
difficult to organize races apart from
the tour ethical issues decide do you
kind of miss Lance Armstrong and the
star factor that he brought to cycling
I'm saw was a very special character and
he's any he will stay this character but
you know we have to look at the future
that's the most important every year
we're talking about the past the past is
the past we can do nothing about that
but that's the rules cycling are very
very tough now and I'm very confident in
the future how confident are you that
this will be a clean race you know you
can ask that for any event in the world
in any sport so but it's fairly say
that's a promise you don't really want
to make right maybe we had a completely
clean nobody can do that I mean nobody
can do that in any event in the world in
his thought if somebody do that he's a
liar